amazon is the king of e-commerce
dominating 49 of the u.s e-commerce
market as of 2018.
with their extraordinary convenience and
praiseworthy customer service
it's no wonder why amazon has grown to
be a customer favorite
in the marketplace despite this gaping
lead though
over the past couple of years walmart
has been slowly
but consistently stacking the cards
against amazon
and at this point it's only a matter of
time until they start stealing serious
market share
away from amazon and here's why
first of all walmart has the proximity
lead by far
amazon has a mere 110 active warehouses
within the us
meanwhile walmart has 4756 stores
just within the us or 43 times as many
as amazon's warehouses
now granted these aren't exactly
warehouses
but they serve the exact same function
for walmart
ninety percent of the u.s population
lives within just a 15-minute drive
from walmart and this makes it
significantly easier for walmart to
offer rapid delivery times
theoretically they could even offer one
hour delivery times to most of their
customers
and this is exactly what walmart is
doing
they don't quite have one hour delivery
but they do have two hour delivery for
ten dollars
amazon does offer something similar with
whole foods
prime members are able to get two hour
deliveries on groceries for free
however there is one key difference
between the two services
amazon service is only applicable to
groceries available
in whole foods while walmart's offering
covers anything that is in stock
in a nearby walmart and here's the thing
walmart has spent decades perfecting
their inventory management
they know exactly what each demographic
wants and
buys so unless you're looking for
something super obscure
it's quite likely that your neighborhood
walmart has it and they can deliver it
to you
in two hours for ten dollars but what if
you don't care to spend ten dollars to
get to our delivery
well walmart offers free next day
delivery on orders above 35
currently this service is limited to
certain areas
but if you live in a major city or one
of its suburbs
it's likely that this is available to
you or will be very soon
anyways as you can see walmart offers a
variety of shipping options like the
ones we just discussed
that match or even beat amazon prime's
delivery options
and walmart is able to do all of it
without a subscription
the problem for amazon is that their
retail business
is not exactly profitable they have been
able to report some overall profits for
the retail business
over the past couple of years but the
logistics part of their business
is still burning tens of billions every
single year
and the only reason amazon is able to
post profits is because of revenue from
amazon prime
and their other services a large part of
this can be explained by amazon's
inferior logistics system
which costs more than walmart's
logistics system don't get me wrong here
amazon's logistics system is one of the
best in the entire world
but walmart does have an upper hand in
this realm as well
the main problem for amazon is that a
lot of their delivery infrastructure
is still dependent on other logistics
companies like ups
and fedex meanwhile walmart has been
running a well-oiled logistics operation
for decades just take a look at the
stats
walmart owns 61 000 trailers while
amazon
owns 20 000 trailers as for planes on
the other hand
amazon actually has 80 planes while
walmart has none
they do have 22 private jets for
corporate use
but they don't use plans for logistics
while that may sound like a disadvantage
at first glance this is actually a huge
advantage
air shipping is not cheap and companies
like customers will always choose ground
delivery if they can afford the time
delay
amazon has been consistently growing
their air fleet as they cannot keep up
with growing demand using just ground
delivery options
in fact they just bought 12 more planes
earlier this year
to help ease increased demand even with
this though
amazon's delivery times have been
seriously slipping throughout the
pandemic
this is completely understandable and
it's not really amazon's fault
but here's the deal walmart has even
more demand
than amazon amazon's net revenue in 2019
was a massive 280.52 billion dollars
walmart's revenue though was even higher
at 514.41 billion
so not only does walmart pull in over
200 billion dollars more in annual
revenue
but they also have to supply 4 700
stores
while amazon only has to supply 110
warehouses
despite all of that walmart is able to
stick to regular old semi trucks
saving billions on jet fuel clearly
walmart wins in infrastructure
and logistics which allows them to offer
the same delivery services
as amazon for free but price
is not the only arena in which walmart
wins either
we also have quality and convenience
starting with quality
walmart isn't exactly known for super
high quality products or anything like
that
however they are often able to offer
better quality
than amazon especially when it comes to
amazon fba products
amazon fba is amazon service where
sellers are able to send inventory to
amazon's warehouses
and amazon will deliver their products
for the seller this
is of course one of the most popular
ecommerce businesses to start
and it has created somewhat passive
income for many many people
though this business model is great for
amazon and sellers
this is not always great for customers
as there are so many people who have to
profit
along the way and considering that these
are generally small businesses
and manufacturers that are selling on
amazon they need solid margins to make
the endeavor worthwhile
successful amazon sellers may be
profiting six or even seven figures
annually
but that's generally the limit though
these sellers are making a solid income
they generally don't have the capital
experience or manufacturing capability
to go to eight or nine figures while
this may not be a problem to the sellers
this hinders amazon's ability to ever
truly reach economies of skill
you see amazon is essentially a
conglomeration of tens of thousands of
multi-million dollar businesses
with profit margins of 20 or 30 percent
concurrently
walmart is a conglomeration of hundreds
of multi-billion dollar businesses
who can afford to have meager profit
margins in the single digit range
walmart is starting to open the doors
for small sellers
but this is still in the early stages
and most of their products are still
from large corporations
or themselves with that being said the
same product from walmart will likely be
cheaper
or of better quality or both and that
brings me on to the final major
advantage for walmart which is the
convenience of returning or exchanging a
product
amazon has tried their best to make the
process of returns
as easy as possible but despite their
efforts
it's simply easier to return a product
on your next trip to walmart
as opposed to shipping it back now
amazon does still have a few advantages
over walmart for instance amazon has a
way superior customer service
and walmart can't really compete against
amazon on variety
considering all of this though walmart
is in the perfect position to take on
amazon throughout this decade
and if you don't believe me just take a
look at their respective stock growth
as investors have taken notice of all of
this and they have started to pour their
money into walmart stock
as we can see walmart stock struggled to
grow for over a decade
in the early 2000s as they refused to
really embrace e-commerce
since walmart started focusing on
e-commerce a couple of years ago though
the stock price has nearly tripled
meanwhile
amazon stock has basically done nothing
over the past couple of years
since they reached the share price of
2000 in mid-2018
amazon stock just started going sideways
the pandemic
actually helped amazon break out of this
stagnation as investors
poured in during mid 2020 hoping to
capitalize on amazon's dominance during
the pandemic
since then though amazon has gone
sideways at the 3 000
mark for the last 7 months and honestly
i think there's a good chance that they
would still be going sideways at the 2
mark if it wasn't for the pandemic but
this begs the question
why are consumers not gushing over
walmart as they often do
with amazon prime i mean amazon has
basically become a verb like google
if you need something one of the first
things you might say
is i'll buy it on amazon not very many
people consider ordering online from
walmart despite
their advantages at this point in time
so
what could explain this well the answer
is simple
people don't like to change from what
they're used to unless they see a
significant difference
it took decades for amazon to convince
people what to buy online
and get an amazon prime membership but
now that they are finally used to buying
on amazon
they're reluctant to switch despite the
savings
moreover for existing amazon prime
members many of them
feel like they're wasting their
membership if they don't actually buy
products from amazon
something else keep in mind is that
people who are already amazon prime
members
have already accepted paying the yearly
membership so
their perceived savings is not as high
if amazon continues to raise a
membership fee though
we may see less people renew considering
this
the real market for walmart today is
individuals who are not yet amazon prime
members
as these individuals are not committed
to buying from any one retailer
as walmart starts to capture serious
market share in this segment
we may very well see walmart eat into
amazon's core audience
as well in the end walmart wins across
the board in terms of skill
they have more stores better logistics
stronger suppliers
and no annual fees which has given
walmart a massive advantage in terms of
price
quality and convenience this doesn't
mean that amazon is going to die
or go bankrupt or anything like that in
fact
their revenues may not even drop as
consumer spending continues to increase
year after year however their market
share is likely to drop
as walmart and other mass retailers like
target and best buy
continue to scale up their online
presence using what they're good at
as opposed to what amazon is good at did
you guys realize walmart was offering
these services
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys love shopping on amazon
but are glad that more options are
entering the market and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then
i'm hari and i'll see you guys on the
next one